clark county commissioner justin jones
is an avid bike rider one day after that
crash he
wants us all to be better and safer on
the road kate houston explains
yes commissioner jones has been cycling
for 15 years during that time he's
worked
closely with local organizations to
promote safe riding
here in southern nevada jones says while
there are laws to protect cyclists
more needs to be done he says often
times major changes aren't made until
after a tragedy happens
much like the one that occurred
yesterday jones wants motorists to
understand that
cyclists have the right to be in the
lane of travel and they should be given
three feet of room
commissioner jones tells me the cycling
community in southern nevada is very
close
and what happened yesterday has had a
profound impact
yesterday was a tough day a lot of my
friends
who are cyclists it was just it's a
rough time
you know they're one of my good friends
uh he said he's
he's likely done with with uh road
biking because of this
he unfortunately got hit by a motorist a
year or so ago
and uh you know we we need to be able to
to to not
throw in the towel right we need to be
able to be in a situation where you can
feel safe
getting out there on on bikes because
it's it's what a lot of us love
right now commissioner jones is working
with the southern nevada bicycle
coalition
and ghost bikes to encourage safe
cycling
he wants southern nevadans to use this
as an opportunity to remind themselves
of the laws that are in place to protect
both drivers
and cyclists he tells me his heart is
with the families of those that died
and with those that were there to
witness what happened he's worried that
the trauma will be long lasting
back to you